well in case you're wondering if it's
really a spiritual war we're watching
here's this news story illinois
elementary school is offering an
after-school satan club the local school
district is defending the satan club
it's sponsored by the satanic temple of
the united states the club claims it
will help kids learn benevolence and
empathy as well as quote personal
sovereignty we're going to the source on
this story lucian graves is with the
satanic temple and joins us tonight
mr graves thanks so much uh for coming
on so i have to ask are are parents
complaining that there's an after-school
satan club
at their children's school
some are but they don't have to send
their children to the program it's
available for parents who do want to
send their children to the program and
it's there as an alternative to
religious clubs that are made to
proselytize to children ours doesn't
include items of religious opinion it
doesn't include indoctrination it just
has a self-directed learning program
with trained educators there to help
guide the children through different
activities
they want to engage in where are the
satan clubs trained educators trained is
there as they're seeing
no we've uh we've got educators who have
volunteered with us we vet them we do
the criminal background checks that
aren't required of after school clubs
and haven't been required of any of the
religious clubs because we want to be
responsible about this
and
we we make sure that they understand the
curriculum they understand what we want
to do in this program and that they're
able to execute that
uh i love your use of the word execute
um so i have any school administrators
said look i know you can like lecture me
about religious freedom but you're a
satan club but we're not going to let
little kids go to the satan club is
anybody or are they just passive like
everyone else in america and kind of
letting it happen
well that's not being passive that's
understanding what the law is that's
understanding what the constitution is
that's understanding what free speech is
and what religious liberty is and
there's a lot of people who express a
lot of uproar about this and they go to
the school board they complain to the
principals they complain to the
superintendent but a school board cannot
overturn the supreme court well actually
so could there be an i hate gays club or
black people or inferior club and the
answer of course is no because the
community and i'm not advocating for
either one of those things but the
community has some say
in what its kids are exposed to
on government property i.e a public
school so so you're just telling me that
everyone's just kind of going along with
it because supreme court
well the supreme court allowed in
religion they said that not having
religious clubs would be religious
discrimination i disagree i think you
can categorically deny religion but what
you can't do is give the government the
opportunity to pick and choose between
which religious viewpoints they'll allow
but they do all they do what they do all
the time i mean you can be suspended
from school for quoting portions of the
old testament like immediately you could
be i mean what i'm trying not to to use
profanity on the air but you're saying
is ridiculous we both know it's
ridiculous and i just i just want to be
really clear on this because to me it's
another example of people just sitting
back at me like oh i guess i have to you
know let's have their drag time story
hour for fourth graders like that you
know i can't say anything and you're
confirming that everyone feels that way
they kind of have to go along with it
for some reason
well people get upset about it people
like you and they don't reconcile their
viewpoints on free speech and religious
liberty i don't know what you're
suggesting i don't know if you're
suggesting if the school board should
say no this is not allowed and we're
going against the supreme court ruling
what i'm saying is you ought to be
allowed to quote the new testament out
loud in school if i mean if we're going
to apply the standard which i suppose
i'd be happy to live under we have to
apply it equally but it's not applied
equally as you know and i suppose i mean
have you been in time i don't know the
new testament story you're speaking of
but we would have sent anybody's right
to practice their religion and we're not
asking for other religious clubs to be
taken out look i'm not even equal access
right and i'm just saying the school
would not provide that
if it were an expression of orthodox
christianity as you know um but lucian
graves i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else